joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is the manager of the los
angeles dodgers dave roberts how are you
skip how are you
rich i'm doing well man it's good to
connect with you it's been uh too long
well how about this it's been longer
than both of us would have hoped how
does that sound fair that's fair but i
think we have a lot to talk about which
is good well you're ncaa tournament
bracket right
dave that's what i'm that's what i'm
referring to absolutely
talk brewing basketball
now yes i mean uh we got bru you got the
ucla and usc uh both in here uh we all
know uh again
what we're uh congratulations on being
named manager of the nl all-star team
before there's even a pitch
dave thank you very much no i'll tell
you this though it's gonna be fun i mean
i don't remember the last time the
dodger dodger stadium the city of los
angeles held an all-star game so as we
get to the summer uh classic this can be
a lot of fun well you're giving the fans
a little idea of what they may look like
because the the lineup uh that it
appears that you'll be able to fill in
is is somewhat ridiculous
um what can you tell me about uh freddie
freeman best you can right now well yeah
as best i can once it i mean obviously
it's been out there and uh it's coming
to pass it's you know once it's
officially official obviously there's
physical that's to go by i haven't put
my arms around them yet but uh had a
chance to chat with them last night and
uh so you know if it comes to pass which
we all expect
it's a special team a special lineup and
this guy uh you know is one of the best
players in all the baseball and to
acquire a guy like that to an already
very good ball club um
is crazy and he's a southern california
guy
so you know grew up in atlanta as far as
with the braves but to come out west i
know uh he and his wife chelsea are
they're very excited so um you have
already spoken with him last night i
have i i have it was it was a quick like
kind of uh you know let's get this thing
done and he's very excited so i just had
my morning meeting so uh
there was a there was a different buzz
in the clubhouse
i i bet so so um you know when it all
comes down to it obviously you have so
many options with your lineup right now
um the question is is you know so when
when do you think it might become
official with with freddie freeman
you know i i would say hopefully uh
sooner than later you know in the next
day i mean i hope today or tomorrow um
but i think that yeah rich you know i
think across industries and i think that
baseball has been been the forefront i
think the dodgers in particular as far
as talking about depth
and when you're talking about 162 games
um the depth you seem to always tap into
it and so when you have a lot of good
players that are versatile um it just
kind of allows you to get to a season
and i think that certainly there's some
sacrifice and some cost individually
with players which i'm having those
conversations but at the end of the day
is trying to bring a championship back
to los angeles and you know freddie and
the players around him uh give us the
best chance to do that dave roberts l.a
dodgers manager joining me here on the
rich eisen show on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line and you just again for
the terrestrial radio audience that just
joined us uh you spoke to freddie
freeman briefly last night is there any
anything you can share with us with the
conversation you had with you no it's
just more of let's just get through the
physical let's get them in camp and uh
it was a mutual kind of excitement and
you know i can't give uh you know
ownership mark walter and andrew
friedman and baseball ops enough credit
for getting something like this done but
uh obviously i'm pretty excited rich but
i'm i'm trying to temper the joy
um but i'm not doing a great job of it
well again i know that it's tough to
talk about something that's not yet
official and anything can happen and
things of that nature so hypothetically
where do do you see him between the
turners and the three-hole is that
something that you're you're you would
be
um yeah
conversation with him i think that he he
certainly earned that and it's kind of i
see him in the two or the three um so
kind of how i put together the lineup
but i'm certainly going to have a
conversation with him okay and now that
you i mean
[Music]
you're not used to having a dh uh more
than just a few times a year but now
you're going to have one for all 162.
who who would that candidate be for the
for the election you know what and it's
funny is that i've always been sort of
the advocate of uh
you know uh the senior circuit and
having
the the the picture and the double
switches and and all that kind of stuff
and not have the dh but um
you know with our roster
it certainly alleviates a little bit of
friction because uh there's a spot that
a guy can take forward bats in a night
so i think for us it's not going to be
that traditional dh it's kind of
revolving uh with a lot of different
guys i think you know jt is one i think
you know max get him in there um you
know will smith you know when he's not
catching maybe give him a a day or two
as a d8 to keep his bat in there so just
to kind of get guys off their feet keep
their bat in there probably most makes
the most sense uh you know with the way
our roster is constructed so you liked
the nl way of doing it i can't believe
i'm going to call it this the the old
way of doing it but now that you've got
the al way of doing it is it grown on
you you kind of dig it right it's it
it's grown pretty quickly um and i and i
understand you know as far as the fans
and you know have an extra hitter in
there
as opposed to a pitcher you know taking
a couple two or three at bats in a night
um and you know you want to see that
hitter and guys like a nelson cruz for
example i'm a huge fan so to keep guys
like that uh relevant in the game
participating contributing i think that
there's something to be said for that
but i'm like you rich i just love the
strategy and you know when to pull a
picture when to you know pinch hit and
uh you know the double switching and
stuff like that it's just it just i like
that kind of cerebral part of the game
okay so um you know i we we let's talk
pitching then um how does your staff
look right now how do you see your your
rotation going i i like our stuff a lot
um i i think it's certainly uh you know
we we do a good job of the depth piece
um
and obviously the pen
but obviously walker bueller julio
yurius uh clayton kershaw andrew heaney
we we uh
acquired or signed from the angels he's
been with the angels in recent years uh
then you've got david price tony
to kind of fill out the rotation so i
named six guys and we're going to be
even deeper than that because we got
some young guys ryan pepio bobby miller
uh landon nack some guys that you're
going to be hearing about uh richie soon
guys that are coming um but i think that
as far as getting through april and may
i think every manager is going to kind
of agree in the sense of having guys
that can take down multiples to kind of
piggyback the starters who just don't
have that build up
that they're accustomed to in spring
trainings passed well i noticed one name
that didn't get mentioned by you right
there is trevor bauer what can you tell
me about
him
yeah i i i really can't and it's not of
just trying to i just don't have the
information so i think i guess that the
line is i'm just going to kind of focus
on
uh the guys that are in camp and until i
know more um
until he's with us i just can't comment
because i just don't know uh enough
information but i'm sure as time goes on
you know we'll know more okay so right
now you're planning to start 2022
and go for however how long without
trevor power right absolutely yeah yes
sir so um how's kershaw
clayton's doing great you know uh like i
i've told a couple people is he doesn't
do a good job of hiding his emotions so
when he feels good he's pretty jovial
and uh threw alive the other day he felt
really good it's just bodies moving well
and um you know signed a one-year deal
so he and his wife ellen are excited to
come back for one more year and i'm
excited it's just good to have him back
uh throwing the baseball feeling good
and you know over the last couple years
rich he's just gone through so many
injuries and trying to find a way to to
come out and still perform which he's
done but this is the first ballot hall
of famer and uh it's good to see 22 in
the clubhouse so what's the plan for him
i mean are you going to how many innings
do you expect right i mean what because
you're going to want to keep him i what
i do know rich is that he'll be ready
for the first turn
in the rotation i don't know uh you know
where we're going to pencil them in as
far as in what slot
but uh and to your question
i would think three to four is pretty
fair um could we get them into the fifth
inning if all goes well in that first
start
that would be the hope but uh you don't
think three to four is fair and we'll
just have guys behind him and continue
to ramp him up dave roberts la dodgers
manager here on the rich eisen show
again the day after news breaks that
freddie freeman is in the middle of this
lineup i mean bets trey turner freeman
justin turner muncie smith taylor
bellinger if that's where you want to
put him eighth i mean my god pollock are
you gonna like laugh out loud sometimes
when you when you actually start filling
out your lineup card
you know what i i i i it's pretty uh
amazing and i'm not gonna lie i've run a
couple exercises uh i might have run a
couple exercises in days uh prior uh
with him in the lineup and kind of
seeing how it looks so uh it is uh it's
a talented team um but the great thing
about our game is you still got to go
out there and perform and so but i do uh
like the club well i mean it's it's kind
of ridiculous for me to ask it but i'm
going to ask it anyway because you know
it you know the drill i mean you've also
spent time in the northeast where where
it's a pressure cooker just like
anything else
the the expectation is anything short of
winning the the world series is is a
failure
uh dave how do you and i spent time you
know as you mentioned in boston i
understand that that expectation in the
market and um
that's that's los angeles and that's
what you live for that's what you play
for and um you know to have the
expectation of the fan base uh
that's we know that going in and so
i do believe in the process how we go
about i believe in the players uh you
know the coaches front office everyone
so um that's our goal too do you address
that with players like literally throw
it out on a table and say this is uh
this is our expectation level as well do
you do
you know what it it's it's talked about
a little bit um i think for me i'm more
focused on the day at hand um and and
getting better and i think that you know
it's kind of that old adage how you do
anything is how you do everything and so
i think that's something our guys that
mantra our guys have taken to um so when
you do that you know the byproduct with
the talent
you know put you in a position with a
championship but yeah i mean it goes
without saying our goal is to hold that
trophy be the last team standing in
2022. dave roberts a couple more minutes
left with the dodgers manager here on
the rich eisen show so uh uh we're we're
hearing that there's gonna be some sort
of like competition committee similar to
what you know the nfl has or what uh
uh the nba has more i guess attuned to
that where you know in 2023 they're
going to start talking about new rules
changes and whatever but
for sure it looks like the shift might
be uh on its last legs here uh dave what
do you make of that concept
you know i'm sort of you can play both
sides like most things um i i do like
the competition committee uh getting
different
you know i don't know exactly who's on
that committee but but hopefully it's
some field personnel some front office
some ownership so you can kind of
collaborate and kind of come to some
consensus but yeah with the shift um
[Music]
i i definitely like the way that
certainly makes guys like max muncie uh
you you we've talked about freddie
freeman
better baseball players cody bellinger
but i do like the way of you know with
the rules
how they have been you're trying to get
out and so with the shift uh allowable
permissible
to move three guys to the other side of
the diamond put manny machado in short
right field
it's smart um but to kind of play it
more straight um potentially have spikes
on the dirt or just two guys on one side
the infield um i'm okay with it and it's
up to players to just kind of adjust um
you know but i i i can i see it both
ways yeah i see just again i'm just as a
fan obviously you know i i i
i just don't want to see like hardliners
by your lefties that would normally find
grass
being caught by a third baseman out in
right short right center field like
that's just
as a fan it's just i want to see
movement i want to see you you know
we've been talking about your strategy
somewhere i want to see you hitting and
running right i want to see
gappers i want to see guys going from
first to third first to home that's
you know triples you know like that's
the sort of thing i want to see and it
just seems to be missing strike
uh strikeout walk or home run it's what
it seems to be these days and i think
that that's a great point and that's
real that's a real uh
you know that's a really
that that's that narrative that thought
um is is very common and i do believe
that it will take away the
uh just swinging for the fences kind of
narrative where yeah if i'm hitting
balls and lining them
to a short right field and i got a third
baseman there i'm more out to now just
try to elevate and and not try to hit
line drive so now if guys are getting
rewarded for hitting a ball you know in
the 5.5 that tony gwynn hole uh to the
right-handed poolside or the left lefty
and the four hole um yeah and you're
gonna see more action more balls and
play
and uh and that's what fans want do you
see do you like a pitch clock
are you up for that i i do i do and i
think it's one of those things that
players are very adaptable so i think
early on it's going to be something
different but i do think that in between
pitches and and nothing against uh my
old buddy valverde but you know that
human rain delay guys like that walking
around the mountain and uh in between
pitch to kind of speed it up i i think
it's good for the game and it's just
that rhythm that i think that fans
certainly need maybe you should go on
this committee dave i mean seriously why
don't you talk to uh you know mr manfred
and get me on there i'm serious like you
know coaches in the nfl are on the
competition committee i mean frable for
instance is a you know and tomlin's been
on it for a while sean payton used to be
on it i mean you're a former player too
you've got a lot uh why not
i appreciate it and i and i do think
that it shouldn't just be
and i might get a letter in the mail but
uh but i do think that ownership uh it
shouldn't just be management it
shouldn't just you know it should be
kind of everyone that has some skin in
the game and uh you know no one sees
more baseball uh than the field manager
so uh but yeah we'll see how it plays
out okay dave roberts thanks for the
call congratulations man tell me what
are your um
lottery numbers for the powerball can
you share those with me right now can
you number five twenty-two
10 yep
what number is trade turner six there
you go those are my lottery numbers
walker builder 21 how about that okay
come on hold on a minute you're so close
to actually giving him and if that
actually hits dave
what's your powerball the powerball is
give me the highest number guy what's it
what's bellinger's no
okay 50. there you go that's the
powerball
there you go there you go well done
dave roberts thank you sir
those numbers yeah
yeah
me immediately those numbers and hit
that'd be amazing let's pull it together
and see if we could make as much as
freeman
all right
take care dave take care all right guys
take care that's dave roberts everybody
you said make as much as free
mookie's the powerball
fifty five twenty two sixteen six twenty
one sixteen fifty did i get those right
he said five six
ten sixteen twenty one twenty two and
the powerball is fifty we are playing
we are playing it
all right so powerball draws on saturday
and it's 147 so not as much not as much
not as much as freddie freeman plus we
got to take taxes out and then if we
pull we got to divvy it up so
you know nothing short of the piece of
metal will be
guaranteed aaron rodgers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here